hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll i
don't know about you but sometimes it's
enough to just get through the day right
there's a lot of things going on
in our individual lives in the wider
world uh just staying afloat is a bit of
an effort but we would like to do more
than that we would like to take a step
back and really think about how should
we behave as good moral rational nice
people here in the world of course if
you've been listening to the podcast at
all you know that even asking this
question is not enough because the
possible answers about how we should
behave what it means to be a good person
to be moral to be ethical not clear we
have not only disagreements about meta
ethics about how we should justify our
ethical beliefs but about what the
actual ethical beliefs are so today's
guest william mccaskill who goes by will
is someone who is really leading the
push for a very specific
way of thinking about how we should act
how we should be a good person it's
within the tradition of utilitarianism
consequentialism okay the idea that
whatever we do we should judge its moral
worth by what consequences it has what
effects it has on the world and that's
not obviously true i mean it's plausibly
true it's a very reasonable thing to do
but it's not the only way to go there's
alternatives about deontological views
where it's a matter of following the
right rules whatever the consequences
might be
virtue ethics positions which say that
it's about cultivating your virtues not
precisely about how you act and
everything but certainly utilitarianism
is a big player in this game and will
has been one of the most influential in
really turning utilitarianism into a
philosophy of action and thinking about
how it should apply to real world
problems especially sort of big picture
problems he's a leader of the effective
altruism movement we've had uh other
interviews with people like josh green
talking about the best ways we can be
charitable but then also we've had
supporters of the mindscape podcast uh
givewell and the 80 000 hours podcast uh
have advertised here on on mindscape
about ways in which we can be better
altruists okay how when we do want to
give some money away to make the world a
better place what is the best possible
way to do that
in his new book called what we owe the
future will is turning his attention to
a specific question within how to be a
good person which is how much should we
weigh the
lives and statuses and situations of
future people in our calculations so
there's a standard trick in economic
theory where you try to decide you know
what good to do which is discounting the
future which is to say that
roughly speaking we don't count future
situations as much as present situations
and part of that is just we don't know
what the future situations are going to
be now the counter argument to that is
okay sure we don't know therefore
there's some uncertainties and we should
take those uncertainties into
consideration but there's an awful lot
of people who could exist in the future
so this is intellectually fascinating to
me because as a classic example of
taking a big number and multiplying it
by a small fraction right and then the
big number is the possible number of
people who might live in the future and
the small fraction is the probability
that we're correctly getting right what
our current actions are going to imply
for their conditions sometimes we know
sometimes it's pretty obvious like that
destroying the climate and the
atmosphere and the environment of the
earth is probably worse for the future
than keeping it in good working order
right
other times it's less clear you know is
super intelligent artificial
intelligence a big worry what are the
risks from pandemics they're certainly
there but how big are they all these
questions so will has thought very
carefully about all these questions in
fact he did allude to in this podcast
something i wish we had more time to go
into which is his phd thesis which is
not that long ago he's he's a very young
guy uh was about basically
if you don't know the right moral theory
if you're not sure whether it's
utilitarianism or virtue ethics or
deontology you can kind of split the
difference he developed ways to sort of
take the average of the recommended
actions given by all these different
points of view uh and so that's it's a
crucially important question because it
sounds all abstract and there's math
involved and things like that but it has
potentially enormous consequences for
what we do here on earth right now where
we spend our money our attention our
concern and you know honestly if you've
listened to the podcast you know that i
am not convinced by utilitarianism i
think that there are issues there that
kind of gets swept under a little bit by
its advocates and so we talk about that
with will and i'm not
anti-utilitarianism either i'm
open-minded about these things and so
this was a conversation that definitely
gave me lots of food for thought in
thinking about these questions which i
repeat are super duper important
questions that we should all be thinking
about whatever your
views on long-termism itself are
it's an important question one that
matters to us going forward in the world
that's what we do here at mindscape so
let's go
[Music]
will mccaskill welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks so much for having me on
i'm a big fan oh thanks uh and i'm a big
fan too i'm a big fan of uh actually i'm
gonna
disagree with some of your conclusions
but in a very soft way like this is
stuff i don't have fixed opinions about
and
i really am interested in learning more
and hearing how you think about it uh
but i'm certainly a big fan of the idea
of
thinking deeply about morality and how
we should think about it because i
suspect that in this world that we have
of technology and dramatic change our
inborn moral intuitions aren't always up
to the task of guiding us as a
civilization
i completely agree with that
and so
your uh idea about how we should be
thinking is this thing called
long-termism so let's just start with
the basic thing so what is long-termism
and take as much time as you want tell
us why you think that this is the way
that we should be thinking about how to
guide ourselves from moment to moment as
we do live here in the world
thank you
so long termism is a view i defend in my
upper upcoming book what we owe the
future
and
it's about taking seriously the sheer
scale of the future and how high the
stakes are in potentially shaping it
then thinking what are the events that
could happen in our lifetime that really
could be pivotal for the course of
future human trajectory and then
ensuring that we navigate them well
those events so that we can help bring
about a just and prosperous and
long-lasting future
um the sort of thing that our
grandchildren's grandchildren will thank
us for
i mean are great for these grandchildren
but also
there's talk in the book about more
cosmic perspectives right millions
billions of years
yeah so it's taking one thing that's
distinctive about this view is that it's
taking the whole course of the future
seriously so long-termism really means
long-term right not just thinking oh
yeah years decades into the future but
really for how long we might live which
i think is thousands millions or even
billions of years
so
uh yeah i'm just gonna say you know in
some sense sorry there's a delay between
us so i'm gonna keep interrupting you i
don't i don't mean to do so but in some
sense
sure of course we should care about the
long-term future but i think that you're
trying to make a slightly stronger claim
than just the the thing that everyone
would agree that every you know the
future does matter in some sense you
want to say that it matters a lot
it matters a lot and so why might we
have that view um well
a common view in model philosophy is
that
acting or thinking morally is about
taking a certain sort of stance a
certain perspective on the world what
the philosopher henry sidwiq called
looking at the world from the point of
view of the universe so no longer just
from your own particular point of view
but from the subjective uh impartial
standpoint
and so
when you take this point of view of the
universe
what do you see
well
the universe formed 13.8 billion years
ago
earth forms 4.5 billion years ago first
replicators 3.8 billion uk votes 2.7
billion
first animals about 800 million years
ago
listeners of your podcast i'm sure i'll
be familiar human beings 3000 years ago
agricultural level
revolution 12 000 years ago and
scientific revolution really just a few
hundred years ago
and
there's a number of striking things here
one is just how early we are in the
universe
second is how rare we seem to be
a third is how fast things are changing
now compared to the billions of years
that have come
before this
and the final is that maybe if anything
things are kind of speeding up in terms
of these great transitions
but we can also ask just
not just so what's so distinctive about
the present but what does the future of
the universe look like well here are the
kind of two ways in which things could
go like how might the story of the
universe unfold
on one humanity continues to advance
technologically and morally
um and someday we take to the stars
and at this point it's no longer
the story of the universe is no longer
just kind of governed by you know the
really fundamental physical laws about
how
uh start um planets orbit stars and
stars form but you would start to see
human agency is telling like a
significant part of the story of what
happens you have these uh interstellar
settlements you have perhaps you have
galactic megastructures
humans intervening to keep the sun
smaller so that it can burn longer
perhaps even for trillions of years
perhaps lowering suns into black holes
as power sources um perhaps you know
constituting
uh solar systems into giant computers
that's one way the kind of future could
go
and that would last for a very long time
indeed the last stars would burn out
after
uh hundreds of trillions of years
actually a small but steady
stream of collisions of brown dwarfs
would
make that last even longer i think a
million trillion years
um but there's another possible future
which is that humanity
does not get to that point of developing
technologically instead we cause our own
extinction
and then the story of um the universe
would be much as the story of the past
um
it would be stars forming and stars
dying
this ex
it would be galaxies colliding over time
but the universe would be empty it would
be lifeless it would be dead
and so
one of the ways into thinking about
long-termism is taking that perspective
of humanity as a whole
appreciating that wow actually the
what we call history or even long
history two thousand years since
um in the common era is just this like
tiny sliver of time
and there really are some things that
could um that we could do now
that could have this course on humanity
this huge impact on the course of
humanity's future
that's of enormous importance just
because of the sheer time scales
involved because humanity's lifespan
might be truly vast
and one of the ways in which we can
impact that very long-term future is by
ensuring we have a future at all
by preventing human extinction
um there are other ways as well i mean i
think
as well as have ensuring that we have
this kind of long future
that
you know on earth would be hundreds of
millions of years
if we take the stars would be billions
more and but also ensuring that it's
good ensuring that society is actually
one of um you know flourishing rather
than some
authoritarian uh perpetual nightmare
and so
that's the kind of
insight and background into this idea of
long-termism is
taking that perspective seriously
thinking wow this is just huge stakes of
this like tiny sliver of time that we
have
the future is going to be wild and we
should really at least be morally
thinking what are the things we can do
that might be impacting the long term
and how can we make them go better
i think that most of our conversation
will not be very science fictiony but
let's let's lean in a little bit to the
science fiction aspects here i mean
you're talking you you i think in that
uh explanation talked about the future
of humanity
but it might not be humanity uh 10
million years from now right we're we'll
be a very different species not even
taking into account the idea of
technology and our blending with that so
is it
really something else like consciousness
or awareness that you're trying to help
out
yeah like i mean i think there's nothing
you know distinctively special about
homo sapiens i think that
all animals with consciousness have
moral worth um and so i also am a big
proponent of animal welfare than
reducing like factory farming but
another thought here is yeah in the
future there could be uh
very different beings um perhaps they're
artificial intelligences perhaps we've
just
the path of human evolution has uh
continued um
you know i would call them humanity in
the sense that if at least they're
representing values and pursuing goals
that we think of as being good ones
where um if there's a future society
that includes pursuit of knowledge and
love and friendship and happiness and
scientific accomplishment even if that's
being done by beings that are you know
somewhat different from us um i would
still think that's a morally worthwhile
um something morally we should care
about and and you gave us two options
one of which was basically going extinct
and the other was spreading to the stars
is there any third option where we more
or less decide we're happy here on earth
and have some flourishing existence for
the next couple billion years
uh absolutely i mean um
uh i think you know
i sketched this potential future um
of spreading to the stars but
if we do if we played our card rights
the cards like the future would be one
that you know we choose for ourselves
and on the basis of you know what we
think is morally good and moderate and
perhaps in the future that
we would decide like actually
uh you know the universe is a big place
but we want to leave it pristine
um that's a good future we could have
and
even there
even just staying on earth we have
hundreds of millions of years before the
earth is no longer habitable and you
know billions of years
uh before the
um
suns
before our sun dies
so
even on that much more modest scale we
have this enormous feature ahead of us
just to get as science fictiony as we're
going to get um please yeah you talk
about uh
love and the search of knowledge and
things like that these yeah and i agree
these are important things but um
once we start extrapolating a billion
years into the future
how plausible is it that those are not
going to be the important things anymore
like i can at least
vaguely imagine in my mind that if we
did upload ourselves into the matrix
uh
all those values that we have all of the
goals and desires that we have as
organic beings turn out to be
intimately connected to our embodiment
in a biology that wants to eat and
reproduce and so forth and we lose
interest in those things that were so
important to us
when we were just organ
biological organisms i mean this is one
plausible at least conceivable
resolution to the fermi paradox right
you know every technology every
civilization becomes so technologically
advanced that they
fulfill all their needs and become less
ambitious
do you give any credence to that
possibility
um
so i think as a solution to the fermi
paradox i don't give it enough credence
where
for there to be some filter from on the
evolution of life from
something like an earth to
uh
very technologically advanced species
kind of spread out across the galaxy
because they're just so many planets and
so any solar systems you really need
this really hard filter right so it
would have to be that 99.999999999
of civilizations
decides to be unambitious and it seems
hard for me to believe that it could be
that high
but you do raise a very important point
which is that the values that guide the
future might be
in fact probably will be quite different
from the values that guide society now
and that could be very good or it could
be very bad
so it could be very good if we've made
moral progress
where
you know from the perspective of the
roman empire the values that guide um
society or um today are very different
we don't own slaves whereas our honor
gone we're wimpy women have political
office but this is all very good things
uh it seems like this is kind of moral
progress
and that could continue into the future
such that our distant descendants
um have made further moral progress and
if
we they value different things and
pursue different goals but if we could
have a conversation with them with
sufficient time
we would they would convince us that
those goals were actually admittable in
the way that hopefully with sufficient
time perhaps i could convince at least
you know maybe i couldn't convince nero
or caligula but i could convince
aristotle i think that owning slaves is
morally wrong
okay um so that's one way to go but then
the second is that it could be just
dystopian like
perhaps
um
perhaps we've ended moral progress too
soon perhaps some fascist ideology just
took over and influenced its values
indefinitely
um or perhaps it's just some very alien
set of goals because we made some
mistake perhaps on the development of ai
and the ai systems themselves took over
and pursued some
just
fundamentally valueless goal
and that's a set of worries that i'm
very concerned about i think gets
neglected and i call value lock-in this
idea that certain bad values or could
take control and then just invent
themselves keep themselves there
indefinitely
okay uh thank you for indulging my
science fiction e questions because
there's a lot of pretty down-to-earth uh
moral and ethical and political
questions involved with the philosophy
of long-termism so
uh am i right to disc to contrast
long-termism with a more conventional uh
economic strategy of temporal
discounting you know in in economics we
we know there will be people in the
future and we do count their value a
little bit but we count it less as a
very explicit move and it seems that
long-termism is saying that's a mistake
um broadly yes so there are some good
reasons for discounting the future
one is if you can invest money that you
have and get a turn on it
then money earlier there's worth more
because you get
further years of investment returns or
if you think that you as an individual
or society are going to be a veteran in
the future
then you should discount just because
money has diminishing returns so
um you know people
are poorer today than they are in 25
years you might think in the same way
that we today are richer than we were 50
years ago
but then there's this final reason that
economists discount the future which
they call the rate of pure time
preference where you just say
a given benefit or harm and not just
talking about money but talking about
anything is intrinsically worth less
year on year and a typical value they
might give is like two percent so a
happy day today is worth
two percent more than a happy day in a
year's time
but this gets really absurd once you
start considering i mean i think it's
absurd at any point in time but i think
it gets really absurd once you consider
long time scales
so suppose i can give you a model choice
you can prevent a single death
in 10 000 years or you can prevent the
genocide of a million people in 11 000
years and suppose there are no other
kind of knock-on effects of these two
things uh which do you think you want to
do
[Laughter]
i'll just be the naive answer here and
say i would prevent all the large number
of deaths
um well i think you've got the correct
answer there
saving a million lives is more important
than saving one life even if the million
lives are in 11 000 years and the one
life in ten thousand but if you have
this
rate of pure time preference that
economists sometimes use of two percent
per year then you think it's more
important to save the one life in 10 000
years than the million lives in 11 000
years and that is absurd i think
everyone would agree all the economists
as well who are normally discounting
over much smaller time frames a few
years or a few decades would agree
that's absurd as well and in the very
long term we should not discount the
future in that way
there's a
at least an analogy to sort of spatial
discounting and this has been one of the
emphases peter singer and other people
have uh put on how we should think about
morality that we tend to value
ourselves and our friends and people
near to us more than people far away and
maybe we shouldn't it's sort of spatial
discounting and and is that a good
analogy or is it basically perfect or is
it very different considerations i mean
i think it's a great analogy um
in particular because the distinction
between space and time
um is not that clean cut um
and
if you dis
i mean it gets a little technical but if
you want to discount a class time but
not across space then you get into all
sorts of paradoxes um
because of general relativity
but on a fundamental ethical level look
it just seems obvious that
the well-being of someone
doesn't diminish if they move further
away from you in space someone on the
other side of the world
matters modelly there
they have a life too they have interest
hopes
joys fears they suffer and if you can
prevent that suffering or avoid harming
them you walk kind of modelly to do so
and similarly just the fact that someone
lives
in a centuries time or a thousand years
time or even a million years time
should not matter
when we're considering kind of how
important are their interests um is it
wrong to harm them
but so this is where my skepticism
begins to arise right i keep calling it
skepticism but that's too strong my my
lack of clarity begins to arise uh
i i get the kind of
philosophical
appeal of the idea that lives matter
equally no matter where they are no
matter when they are
but as a practical matter i mean you
know singers original uh examples of
saving someone who's drowning in a pond
in front of you versus saving someone
who is in a different continent
it seems to be perfectly okay to save
the person that you're looking at and
worry about that care about that more
than someone who's far away just because
i know terrible things are happening far
away and i i'm not in favor of it
i would like them to not happen but the
actions i'm going to take in response to
them are just not going to be of the
same order as the actions that i see
happening right in front of me and and
maybe that's okay do you
what side do you come down upon that
uh yeah i want to say two things so
one is that um
i do think we have some
extra reasons to care about people in
the present generation compared to
people in future generations
and in the same way i have special
reasons to care about people near and
dear to me compared to distant strangers
so a couple of reasons one is just
special relationships
if
if you're my mom that gives me an
additional reason to care about you
um
similarly with you know friendships
possibly with compete fiats that's you
know lay me a little bit less clear
but i think everyone you know is a very
intuitive view that if you can save
one person from dying or two people from
dying and the one person is your spouse
or a family member then yeah it's fine
to save the one
um a second reason is reciprocity as
well so
by being embedded in society people have
given me enormous gifts education i've
received again this compounds the
special obligations i have to my parents
um
uh also to like you know
teachers that have helped me all these
sorts of benefits also just benefits of
receipt from the state all these sorts
of benefits and i have some kind of
obligation to be repay them but
people in distance cult distant
nations uh they still mattered a lot
i still am not justified in harming them
in order to even to benefit my family
and in so far as i have disposable
income money i would otherwise spend on
luxuries like
um you know nicer clothes or a nicer
house or things i don't really need
then that's not conflicting with these
obligations of their simplicity or
partiality and i can help them and i
think the same is true when we look at
future people so
i don't have special relationships with
them in particular
um perhaps if i have children they'll
have you know great great grandkids but
uh perhaps that that gives me some extra
reason but
that's not true for most future people
um and i certainly don't have a
relationship of reciprocity with them
um perhaps i have some sort of passing
the baton
obligation where past generations have
benefited me enormously through
innovation through
model change that people fought for
through laws and political systems have
been developed perhaps that gives me a
reason to pay it forward
but i think the fundamental thing is
that people we owe what people at least
we owe people in the future at least
what we owe strangers in the present and
that might not be as much as we owe our
near and dear but it's still an awful
lot and it still really makes a big
difference for how we act morally i
think
well there is at least one dis analogy
in that the people who are far away
exist
and the people who are in the future
may or may not exist right i mean there
is there's some sort of uncertainties
involved in thinking about
caring for future generations that are
less of a worry when we're just caring
about people who exist right now but are
far away from us
sure so yeah uncertainty is huge of
course
and
in what we are the future essentially
the whole book is just addressing the
the issue of uncertainty i think a very
reasonable starting point of skepticism
is
well can we really affect any of this
like in a predictable way
and you know i spend
um five chapters
then i argue yes
um but even then it's still thought with
uncertainty
but that i think doesn't undermine the
fundamental moral issues so
the va you know singer has this thought
experiment you can walk into a shallow
pond and save a child's life ruin your
suit
now suppose you're not certain it's a
child you think it's probably a child
but could just be a
you know a boy or something a buoy as
you would americans would say
um
i think you should still go in and save
the kids like uncertainty is often used
as a justification for an action but i
think it's a very bad justification so
in climate
science or the discussion around climate
change people say oh well we don't
really know
what the impacts of climate change will
be exactly and that's true to an extent
but it doesn't justify inaction i think
if anything it justifies further
inaction further action than we might
otherwise take because things could be
much worse than we think
and similarly when thinking about the
future it's like okay yeah we don't know
that people in the future are going to
exist that gives you something of less
of a reason but also things could
be very different from how the pleasant
day are things could be much much better
if we play our cards late
or much much worse in fact if things go
in a dystopian direction
and so if anything uncertainty i think
gives us more reason to act more reason
to take a cautious responsible
um approach to the future rather than
just winging it
yeah no i completely 100 agree that
uncertainty by itself is not an excuse
for inaction i mean we have to do our
best right to weigh the uncertainties
and uh balance them against rewards etc
but it that is hard to do i guess is the
is definitely a lesson that that we
should keep in mind but okay let's just
be as dramatic as we can you know um
you've been very active in thinking
about the possibility of existential
risk so you started by
contrasting a glorious future of of life
in the stars and exploration and love
and discovery versus extinction
so is that how big of a worry is
extinction uh let's grant that it would
be bad uh
but
lots of things would be bad you know i
could quantum tunnel through the floor
of the building i'm on right now it's
just so unlikely that i don't worry
about it how likely or unlikely are
these existential risks are they things
that should affect our day-to-day
planning or at least our social planning
i think this should certainly affect our
social planning
um so i'll focus just on
pandemics as one source of existential
risk
where
you know we as a community were really
worried about pandemics for many years
you know making donations in the area
encouraging people to go into career
choices from
2014 onwards um
and people didn't pay all that much
attention
um unfortunately unfortunately
uh
but i think
and you know we got the covered 19
pandemic showed us that we are not
immune in the modern world to a pandemic
but in many ways
in covet 19 was much less bad than it
could have been so it's an enormous
colossal tragedy but the virus could
have been more deadly it could have been
more infectious
and when we look to developments over
the coming decades i think we have
reason to worry to expect things to get
potentially worse because we don't just
have to conflict with uh
uh wrestle with
natural pandemics but we'll increasingly
be able to
create engineered pandemics
namely by
creating new viruses new pathogens
or upgrading existing ones
and
that could really leak destruction on an
enormous scale that i think i think it's
unlikely i think it's you know one
percent or less that it could reach this
within our within the coming century
that it could reach the scale of killing
everybody
um
but
one percent that's you're more likely to
die of that than in a fire or from
drowning um if you got on a plane and
it's like oh
only one in a thousand chance of dying
on this plane i don't think you get i
don't think you get on it
um
and
that means that we as a society should
and then so it's a real you know
non-negligible risk
um and the stakes would be
extraordinarily great
the work that one does to prevent
pandemics which i'm happy to talk more
about um have it has enormous other
benefits in the near term too
um
in such that often this work is just
justified on
you know without even having to think
about the long-term future
uh
and it does you know has particular
policy prescriptions it means we should
perhaps be more cautious about
certain areas of bio technological
advancement i think it should be means
we should be even more concerned
about the potential outbreak of a third
world war or some other war between
great powers
where i think the risk of using bio
weapons and engineer pathogens goes up a
lot in wartime when people start doing
very dumb
things is there something about our
current moment uh historically a moment
broadly construed you know plus or minus
a few hundred years that is especially
perilous you know we we've come across
new technologies in the last hundred
years that we didn't have before
and
[Music]
our threat to ourselves is greater than
ever before
is that just the permanent future
condition and we've had a phase
transition or is it a temporary case
where we're going to become safe again
down the road uh i think there's a good
argument for thinking it's
temporary um or at least
that the rate of technological change
we've seen can't persist
indefinitely and that we're living
through can't persist indefinitely um
where
you know
we've only had really evaporates of tech
progress for a few hundred years
um but again
the you know even on earth the human
race could survive for hundreds of
millions of years
well if we have this continued rate of
technological advancement
even for thousands of years what happens
well
how do you measure tech advancement is
hard but let's just use the kind of
economic measure like contribution to
economic growth
of again about two percent per year
globally
um
well
we have an economy of a certain size now
continuation of two percent per year
growth for 10 000 years
means that the economy would be i think
10 to the power 89 times as big as it is
to the day today there are 10 to the
power 67 like atoms within 10 000 light
years
so it would mean that we would have this
economy of um you know a trillion
civilizations for every atom we could
access and it's just like it's just not
plausible that we're going to have
that much technological advancement so
things have to slow
and so what this means is that we're
living through a period of unusually
fast technological progress and usually
fast compared to history or compared to
the future
and if every technology is just you're
reaching into an urn and you're drawing
a ball and most of the time it's just
like it's great technology in general
has just been enormous really important
in terms of improving our lives but you
get dual use technologies so nuclear
fission
um
well could have and could still give us
abundant clean energy but it also gives
us the power to develop nuclear weapons
similarly advances in biotechnology i
think could
do a huge amount to eradicating disease
but could also help us create
you know new pathogens
i think similarly with artificial
intelligence could bring about a new era
of prosperity um could also
uh enable dictatorial lock-in or
result in a future where artificial
systems themselves control things and
human values are kind of out of the loop
uh
so that's why i think like things are
particularly important now
um
and then will we ever get to a state
where we can just reduce
existential risk to zero
basically i don't know
um if we can't then we've got no future
we're kind of doomed anyway
but maybe we can maybe we can get to a
position of what my colleague tobiah
calls existential security where we've
actually just like matured as a species
we've figured stuff out we've managed to
get these risks all the relevant risks
down to zero and then we can continue
um
with civilization's trajectory
and if you think that's 50 50 well i
think those are odds worth betting on at
least
well okay good so this now we're getting
into the slightly more technical
questions here because
a lot of this seems to and maybe it
doesn't maybe i have a misimpression but
it seems to depend on these
probabilities i mean you said okay one
percent chance of a pandemic that would
wipe out all of humanity and i
completely agree that one percent for
that particular kind of number is
enormously big and we should worry about
it a lot
but if it's 10 to the minus 10 chance or
10 minus 100 chance then maybe things
are different i don't know so like how
do we know what these crazy small
probabilities are i guess there's
there's a bigger question here that i
always worry about even though i'm a
very good bayesian i think that's how
you should think about things
multiplying really small probabilities
times really big effects is just always
really dangerous to me i mean have you
have you have we learned about a better
way of doing that or do we just do our
best and cross our fingers
so on the issue of tiny probabilities of
very large amounts of
value i just completely agree um if the
arguments i was presenting
were about 100 trillion trillionth alien
chance of such and no mistakes right
then i'm like i would not have written
this book i'd be doing something else
promoting something else
and
actually many of my colleagues at this
institute
global priorities institute i helped to
set up have worked on this very topic of
how do you handle tiny probabilities of
enormous amounts of value
and i'm sorry to say that the bigger
results have been impossibility of
results so just showing that no
plausible view in fact proving that no
plausible view sorry no view you can
have on this topic
has implications that are just generally
plausible there's just you've got some
like a very unintuitive implications um
for all such views
however
thankfully we're not in that world
so it's kind of philosophically
interesting
but
the probabilities of the risks we're
facing
um are really completely sizable you
know of this of just the same sort of
magnitude as um
risks from
you know dying in a car crash higher
than the risks of dying in a plane clash
exactly the sort of
you know threats that we typically worry
about
so my again my colleague toby odd puts
the overall chance at about
one in six
of existential risk in our lifetime
and i don't significantly disagree with
him um on that that i have like some
differences in
how we might lose most future value um
but not uh
enormous differences in
um
the fact that yeah the size of these
risks really are very great
and then when you consider the fact that
most of the work you're doing to reduce
these extinction risks are also helping
to reduce
just catastrophe so
what's the chance that we get a pandemic
far worse than covert 19
um in our lifetimes i'd say considerably
worse than covert 19 i'd say one in
three perhaps
um what's the chance of like a world war
iii um you know war between great powers
in our lifetime again i'd say at least
25
um
could even argue to go higher um
you ask the question of how do we
even assess these probabilities um and
it's super hard and i think there's just
enormous amounts of work we can do to
try and get these more and more precise
but one thing we can do to start making
estimates a little more reliable
is uh the kind of what's called the art
and science of forecasting
where you get lots of individuals who
each come up with their kind of own best
guess judgment on the probability of
something or some sort of forecast and
then you use certain algorithms to
aggregate those forecasts into kind of
an all things considered prediction
and so um
there's a community platform community
prediction platform called mintaculous
um that does this but like in a
uh among kind of aggregating predictions
among many people
uh back in 26 2015 i think it made a
prediction what's the chance of a
pandemic that kills at least 10 million
people occurring between 2016 and uh
2026 and it gave one in three was the
answer
and if you thought it was one in three
we would have taken a lot more
precautions that would have done pretty
well
and so then when i said
the risk of a biological catastrophe was
something like one in one percent maybe
a bit lower uh that was again appealing
to mitaculous where
its estimate of
the chance of
an engineered pathogen that kills at
least 95 percent of the world's
population is about 0.9
and then like what fraction of that goes
to extinction it's hard to say maybe
it's 0.5 percent in total risk of
extinction
so you know i'm trying to use the
aggregate of many many people each
having them takes but i think this seems
a little bit different than
pure long-termism i mean sure i do want
to avoid the extinction of the human
race and it is absolutely true as you
say that many of the things we can do to
avoid the extinction of the human race
are good for other reasons like you also
want to avoid the extinction of half the
human race but how do we connect that
or let me put it this way why do we need
to care about a billion years in the
future to talk like that i mean i don't
want to especially if the the worse
risks are in the next thousand years uh
isn't this compatible with a much more
near-termism like don't do things that
could wipe us out in the couple next
couple centuries
uh i mean i completely agree basically
um and uh
it was
um yeah this kind of intro i was giving
was me
experimenting with different flamingos
um
where often i just want to say look at
least consider centuries for thousands
of years right because i don't think it
makes an enormous difference whether
we're on a time scale of
thinking thousands of years into the
future or billions of years into the
future but having said that you know i'm
a model philosopher i really want people
to just have the underlying moral views
and the big picture morality correct
where
uh
look there are these enormously passing
reasons in the near term for reducing
risk of catastrophe
for ending stopping the human race from
ending
but
like
as you know i'm hoping that the ideas we
promote in the way that ideas
in the past like liberalism of the
scientific method
continue to have relevance and impact
over decades or even long maybe
centuries maybe even longer
and
for that i just really want people not
just to be acting on the right
conclusions but also have to provide
underlying world view and even if that's
weird and has this initial oh wow this
sounds like sci-fi i'm like okay yeah
but it really isn't
just really start or if you think it is
like explicit you know tell me tell me
why
like i'm really not someone who came in
from a kind of sci-fi background i don't
have much interest in that i just care
about people and i care about them
on the other side of the world
i care about them in
the future too
and
i think it's really more
just important that people in general
have the right moral views such that i
don't know 20 years time
let's say we have got extinction risk
just down to close to zero because of
you know pioneering work by people who
are inspired by some of these ideas
then
i want us to keep acting to try and
benefit the long-term future even if
that might start looking above different
i guess this does uh resonate with
something i worry about a lot which is
that the human brain or human values
anyway uh don't seem very good at
dealing with risks that are less than 50
percent chance over a century right
we just don't care about that uh whether
it's solar flares or pandemics and and
so forth so
i don't want to put words in your mouth
but maybe
if again forgetting about millions or
billions of years in the future maybe
like one kind of obvious moral upgrade
that we could do is just to take
more
pay more attention to things that are
unlikely and but disastrous over a
century time scale
absolutely
so
the way
people learn and society learns tends to
be
a kind of trial and error process
learning from experience
and so look at planes
planes are very very safe
one of the safest modes of transport per
mile and why are they so safe because
there have been a lot of plane crashes
in the past and so over time we've been
able to build better and safer planes
reduce the risk of accidents
pandemics um
kill many many more people per year on
average than plane crashes
um i think we could just take the last
you know i doubt 10 million people have
died in plane crashes over the last 100
years
um
but are we prepared for them no and it's
because
unnatural in terms of natural pandemics
something like covert 19 or the spanish
flu that's like a one in the century
event we don't get to learn from
feedback and the same is true with these
like low somewhat lower probability but
high consequence events if something
happens just every few decades then we
don't learn from experience
and that means what we need of
people who are firstly just clear
thinking and numerate so really
understand
and yeah understand the risks that we
face going forward
and secondly kind of morally motivated
concern to overcome the political
hurdles such that we
take action on them now
because
the situation we face is actually even
harder than for natural pandemics
because at least there we have a history
of um
pandemics to use as evidence but when
we're talking about truly new technology
um you don't have that history so think
about the situation just before
development of the atomic bomb
those who are agitating
for
um u.s political leadership to take such
a possibility seriously were saying you
know you should take really seriously
this technology this event that we have
never seen before and that's pretty
tough and we face i think a similar
situation where we're talking about
the ability to engineer new pathogens
we've never seen that before but
we should be worried we should be
thinking this through or the development
of
intelligent systems that are at human
level or greater than human level um
we should be taking that really
seriously we should be taking it
seriously before
um
before that arises because we don't get
nearly as much feedback as
an ability to learn from trial and error
as we do from these com you know every
day sources of um tragedy like car
crashes playing card clashes um and so
on
and it reminds me of an issue that seems
to come up in democratic governance you
know i've talked a lot about the on the
podcast about democracy and the threats
to it and so forth and recently and
i had a good question in the ask me
anything episode where they said okay so
what is what is the downside of
democracy what is the argument against
it just so we can sort of steal man that
this is probably one right i mean
democracies don't seem to be super good
at long-term planning because the people
you vote for
very naturally
worry about the next 10 years at most is
that am i too cynical about that and is
there something we can do about that
uh yeah i want to say two things on
democracy
one is the question of what exactly
you're democratizing where um with
nuclear weapons um you know they're
terrifying
one way in which we got lucky is that
fissile material is very easy to control
so it's not the case that anyone can
manufacture a nuclear weapon in their
garage um
with future technologies technology
ability to engineer new pathogens
if depending on the regulatory
environment could go a different way
right and so there are some
some sorts of power we don't want to
democratize precisely because they're
um
very dangerous um
so that's one thing and then you're
right that there's this
once you take in seriously the interest
of future generations
the um it seems like democracy has this
major flaw
which is that
of the people that will be impacted by
the policies we choose today
where let's conservatively say that
future generations outnumber us a
thousand to one um
that's just if we live as long as a
typical mammal species that's how many
people there will be
well
then
it's only 1.1 percent representations of
those who are going to be impacted
so what can we do about it though that's
a tougher question
and again in
what we are the future i was going to
have a whole chapter just on um
institutions
dedicated to taking the long term into
consideration and how we can augment
democracy to have a more long-term view
and i ended up not having that chapter
just because i think the situation's a
little bit dismal
there are some things we can do so
you can have an ombudsperson
for future generations so wales has the
future generations commissioner
and their point in government is just to
go around advocating for future
generations issues wow
i really like citizens assemblies
so
this is where you take a randomly
selected sample of the population
so let's say it's a thousand people but
that statistically represent
the united states electorate
and they would get together you would
present them with like various different
issues um that might impact future
generations you tell them to take on the
role of like their great great grandkids
and imagining like okay what should we
be doing in order to
um
make sure that their lives our
descendants lives go well um
and
you get them at least in an advisory
capacity uh to say okay this is what we
think we should do
and
you know these are things that i think
are good
i think that would make the world better
they would help inform government
uh i just think for the far cry from
um
you know seriously taking
the long-term impacts of our elections
um
uh and put you know
end of democratic decisions and having
that in practice
uh and so we can make these incremental
changes but i think
something that's like
trying to represent future generations
in any serious way is just
my guess is that it's impossible because
future generations aren't here yet they
can't represent themselves and so
any system you set up to try and
represent them will have the force of
special interests um aiming to co-opt it
and that's just a tough situation within
i think
all right that was about as cynical as i
am also so i can't really argue with you
uh it is a flaw we should we should
think about apologies trying to do
better yeah you know reality never
promised us a rose garden uh so let's
back up and you are a moral philosopher
and uh we've sketched out some of the
ways in which we do long-termism
thinking but now i want to really dig
into why we should be thinking this way
in the first place and i take it that
your starting point anyway is some kind
of consequentialist utilitarian point of
view so tell us what that is and then
maybe a bit about the meta-ethical why
you think that's the right perspective
to take
terrific so i'll say that
the things i argue for are utilitarian
flavored or consequentialist flavored
insofar as
they
are really focused on what good outcomes
can we promote
um
but
i'm pretty careful to just in public
only defend things that i think are
justified in a wide variety of moral
views
and
my second book was an academic book
is precisely and my phd topic was
precisely on this question of
on this issue where i think you should
have some degree of belief in a variety
of different moral views
consequentialism and
non-consequentialism
and when you're taking action you should
try and act in a way that's the best
synthesis or compromise between these
different moral views
um and i think that concern for the long
term is something that would pop out of
that
so but briefly what is consequentialism
consequentialism says
you should do what's best where what's
best is what brings about the best
outcomes
and it says that that's all that matters
um and that's can be unintuitive in one
of two ways
one is it
means that
uh
it's never permissible for me to just
spend some resources on myself for you
know do my own thing if i could do
something else that would be um you know
think about the best outcome so
it's
i could
you know spend the money on a nicer
house or a nicer car but that money
could be used to improve the lives very
significantly of people in very poor
countries or could be used to help steer
the future into a more positive
trajectory
and let's say that which i think is very
likely to be the case
that will do more good overall
from this kind of impartial point of
view then you ought to do it on
consequentialism
the fact you don't shouldn't give
yourself any greater weight than any
others
and that i think is very practically
relevant because um
we in
western countries just do have a lot of
resources that could be used to do a lot
of good
there's a second aspect which can be
unintuitive which is that
promoting good outcomes
is always the right thing to do even if
that involves a kind of means that is
not as well
that we have like a common sense
objection to
so
if you can kill one person to save a
hundred other people
um
then on consequentialism you ought to do
that
now i think that's much less practically
relevant for a couple of reasons
one is that when you do this kind of
compromise between different moral
perspectives
on at least some plausible moral views
people have rights that protects them
against being used as a means
even for the greater good and that's
really serious on those moral views and
so uh
the best compromise i think means we do
respect people's rights while trying to
promote the good in cases where you're
not violating anyone's rights or doing
harm
and then secondly it's just like
how often is the best thing to do to
kill one person to save a hundred it's
just like hasn't come up in my life um
it hasn't come up in the lives of anyone
i know
um
it's the sort of thing that tends to
be more i mean it would come up in
wartime um
but it's the sort of thing that comes up
more in the philosophy seminar room than
in practice
where in practice i think if you're the
good consequentialist you actually want
to be even more scrupulous
you want to go around like being very
very honest being very respectful to
other people being very cooperative
and the effect of altruism community in
general has really tried to promote
those virtues
uh
and so um
but yeah but uh
the key thing is
that makes
the things i promote like effectors in
long-term kind of sound consequentialist
is this rigorous focus on bringing about
you know good consequences making the
world better
but that's something that other moral
viewpoints really care about too
non-consequentialism virtue ethics they
also think that doing good things
matters it's just that they think it's
not the only thing that matters and i
would agree
can i ask i'm actually very intrigued
i'm kind of sad we didn't do a whole
episode on this uh probability
distribution over moral systems and and
using that as a guide to action so i'll
just ask one very simple question would
that
strategy also be applicable to religious
views should we take the expectation
value of what we think god wants us to
do if even if not god exists
uh i mean i think you should give
some
you know am i certain a hundred percent
certain
um that yeah i'm not gonna wake up after
i'm dead and
um
god will tell me that you know i got it
all wrong um no i'm not 100 certain
and then there's this um
very thorny argument going all the way
back to pascal of saying well right if
you've got some credence in god and god
can produce infinite amounts of value
then you should really be waging on god
um
this again
um i'm having to be like a bit of an
apologist for philosophers this again i
think is something where we just don't
have a very good answer um again because
you know we mentioned before this tiny
probabilities of enormous amounts of
value
well this is that that issue that large
right
where it's not tiny probabilities of
enormous mental value it's tiny
probabilities of infinite amounts of
value
and i'm like
i mean my practical attitude is like ah
we haven't figured this stuff out
if i try and take action on it
i feel about is equally likely that i'll
do harm as i'll do good maybe it's like
slightly like more likely that'll
produce infinite positive value and
infinite negative value
but i can't think of a much better
strategy than like trying to
ensure that future generations exist and
they can figure this stuff out
and have more of a clue than i do
um having but like
i think if someone was like this really
hard-nosed bullet-biting
decision therapist
i don't i don't think i have like a good
philosophically justified
response to them to be honest
well i think okay you were careful
in the discussion of uh consequentialism
you didn't emphasize the utilitarian
version of you consequentialism very
much so
i mean maybe explain what makes
utilitarianism special within
consequentialism and then
are you a utilitarian and should we all
be
sure so um
utilitarianism is a form of
consequentialism so consequentialism
says just do what produces the best
consequences utilitarianism has one
particular
understanding of what those consequences
are which is namely the sum total of
people's well-being
so you can like take your action look at
everyone who's impacted
look at all those who are benefited add
up all those benefits
look at all everyone's who's harmed
subtract away those harms that's the
amount of good you've done
and that can be contrasted with views
primarily with views on which things
other than well-being matter so
preservation of the natural environment
knowledge for its own sake perhaps art
for its own sake
just complexity perhaps life itself
uh
and
again i think you should have a view
where you know take lots of different
model perspectives into account i think
in and
act as a compromise uh that does mean
that in practice i would give some
weight to those other things
having said that
at least in the seminar room i find the
arguments in favor of utilitarianism as
compared to other sorts of
consequentialist views
really quite compelling
where
i find it much more plausible that there
could be
moral properties properties that are
good and bad that pertain to conscious
experiences in particular
um
then there's this thing good and bad
that is the property of a natural
landscape or of a piece of human created
art
where it seems to me i have direct
awareness of this
of goodness when i have a good
experience i have direct awareness of
badness when i suffer
i don't have direct awareness of the
goodness or badness of a painting
instead that feels just like some
judgment i have
and that's this uh
crucial distinction it seems to me
between
um
well-being in particular as it consists
in conscious experiences and
other things that are purportedly good
or bad
and that does raise the issue of the
meta ethical justification for all this
i mean why should we be
consequentialist
are you someone who thinks that well we
have moral intuitions and we're trying
to systematize and formalize them or is
there some kind of objective
transcendent argument that this is
simply the right thing
great question so within
the effective autism community and
people who work on this there's a big
diversity of views many people have this
view which is kind of called
sophisticated subjectivism where
what you're doing morally is just trying
to act on the preferences of what an
idealized version of yourself
um would want yourself to want so if you
could just reflect forever that says
ultimately but
this is what you would want to do but
ultimately it's just about your
preferences i actually personally don't
find that view that plausible
um i think it's a kind of
awkward
kind of
halfway house between one of two views
one view is just nihilism or one marvel
floss is called ever theory on which
every time i say some moral claim merge
of this wrong giving to charity is good
it's all false it's like i'm talking
about witches
um
or floggistan it's just a false kind of
view of the world
and honestly i find that be quite
compelling i'm not sure exactly um
what you know probability i give it um
depending on my mood somewhere between
10 and 90 i think
um but then there's this other view
which is that no there actually is like
as part of the fabric of the universe
they're the model
um
truths or at least evaluative truths
yeah uh where yeah on my kind of
preferred view
um those twos have got grounded in
conscious experience
where um there are these famous
arguments forever theory um
so jl maggie uh writing in i think it's
the 70s calls them the argument
arguments from queerness
that moral properties are queer
and it's funny how the term has evolved
because it's like oh yeah these
it sounds like oh these properties are
too gay to exist but um
he's just saying uh
well
if there are moral properties things
that
invert you just understanding them you
think you should promote them that would
make them radically unlike other sorts
of properties like natural properties in
the world
and i'm like yeah they are kind of
different but consciousness is already
just radically different from other
sorts of
things that we find in nature so at
least i've got a bit of a partner in
guilt
argument there
and then he has this second argument
from queerness which is that well how
would we know
if there's this moral property something
we ought to do what's the
what's the like way in which we get to
this truth and again my answer is by
dialect awareness like how do i know
truth is about consciousness it's
because i directly perceive them it's
not because of
anything i know in the kind of
scientific realm and so that i think at
least
you know there's plenty more to be said
but gives us at least some grounding for
thinking that oh no it really could be
the case that there are these
fundamental facts about
um what is good and bad and what we
ought to do and not what to do
and then if you've got
some degree of belief in both nihilism
and um
the model realist view yeah well
you don't there's no chance of making a
mistake by doing the moral realist thing
because if
uh nihilism is true nothing matters and
you know i've spent all my time doing
these good things well the niles is like
as good as anything else
because crucially the nihilism appeals
to reasons i have to benefit myself as
well it's not saying there's no morality
it should just benefit me saying i've
got no reason to do anything yeah um
it'd be uh including
helping myself
so
in that situation you just may as well
do the model realist thing
you may as well act as if there's a
meaning to the and purpose to the world
so even if
doesn't work for god maybe it works for
moral realism
you might as well act that way so if
you well you might as well act that way
to be clear if i thought if i had a
point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent degree of belief in moral
realism i'd be a bit sketched out by the
argument
but really i'm kind of more like 50 50
or something
um it's or at least you know i think
it's
really pretty plausible that this could
be true and so um
that
makes me think this isn't this kind of
crazy pascalian low probability argument
okay i mean again we could talk about
this for a long time but i really want
to start applying it to long-termism and
in the book you have a wonderful chapter
about
population ethics
uh where you sort of give the apologia
for being a utilitarian about uh all the
well-being of the future generations and
so forth and correct me if i'm wrong but
you seem to be careful in that chapter
to really
use utility
the the total well-being of all the
people in the world in a kind of ranking
sense without actually
attaching real numbers to it so i mean
the the skepticism i've had about
utilitarianism has always been
what number are we attaching to the
well-being of a person and how in the
world do you think you can just add them
up for all these people and i mean maybe
there's a weaker version where you don't
really need it to be
an actual number as long as you can
reach conclusions just from saying but
you have to think that this is better
than that
terrific so
uh let's
we'll get on to you to maybe population
ethics next because this first question
of how are you even measuring well-being
yeah
uh is
um kind of more fundamental really
and so
the way that i would
measure well-being
is
by appealing to people's like carefully
considered preferences and the
trade-offs that they would make
um my particular favorite method is uh
time trade-offs
so
um
uh i'm
well you can do both times fade offs or
probability trade-offs um but if i'm
indifferent between
let's say you know i'll definitely die
tomorrow or i can have
uh
two days skiing or one day at the beach
and i'm indifferent between those two
things one day one day at the beach and
then i die two days skiing and then i
die
then
um
plug in as long as my preferences
fulfill certain other axioms
then we can create
what you know is called a ratio scale
such that my preferences where the
fundamental thing is just
preference for x over y it's not like
there are numbers like buried with a
knee
buried
in deep inside me
i just have these preferences for yeah
okay indifference between two days
skiing and one day at the beach perhaps
um i there prefer to either of those
things four days in paris and i just
have preferences over all of these
things the preferences satisfy certain
conditions
then we can use numbers to represent
um
my preferences
and
that's all that's going on the numbers
are just like yeah being used to
represent those things then there's a
second question of like okay that's my
own preferences
um
how do i
come how do we compare
my preferences with yours and so on um
or at least my well-being with yours the
preferences are just a means into what
my well-being is
um
and that's really hard there's like
various philosophical accounts of it but
the thing i want to say is
look if you're saying that it's
you know me pinching you in the shoulder
and
her or and someone else getting
horrifically beaten up there's no
comparison between those things can't
say for whom is that worse i'm just like
come on
um we we obviously know and so perhaps
we
there's debate about like what's the
correct theoretical account of
how we're making comparisons of
well-being differences across different
people but clearly we know we are they
are and in general like
you know you can just look at various
sorts of experiences like headaches are
probably like you know on a similar
range for most people or like other
things like similar range for most
people you can at least kind of roughly
start to make these comparisons
and
that
once you've got that then at least
approximately you're able to
engage in um
you know utilitarian reasoning where you
can meaningfully talk about some total
of people's well-being
well maybe this is fair but i'm not
completely convinced you're not cheating
a little bit here i mean i see the uh
move that you're making which i'm
sympathetic to which is
look if you spend all your time worrying
about the weird edge cases you're going
to miss some basic truths in the simple
cases that actually arise okay good i'm
i'm on board with that i get a very
similar dialogue when i discuss the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics uh but
we're gonna be extrapolating in some
sense right i mean this is what
long-termism is all about i mean
couldn't a skeptic say like no no
until you have a rigorous theory that
works even in the edge cases i'm not
going to believe your extrapolation a
million years into the future
uh
i'm curious on what you see as the edge
cases that we're worrying about
um
like when it comes to
so i guess i guess
my the fundamental all objections to
utilitarianism i think boil down to the
idea that do you really believe that
there is uh if i have a person with a
certain amount of well-being
and another person with much much more
well-being
that there is some difference between
their well-being that is so great that i
am indifferent to uh
the person with
uh
a little bit of well-being
existing
versus a 50 chance that the person with
a lot of well-being exists versus a 50
chance that nobody exists
you know can i take that expectation
value like those seem a little bit
incommensurable in some sense to me but
it kind of lies at the heart of what
utilitarianism asks me to do
uh
so i think two things to say one is at
least on the
you know utilitarianism doesn't yet make
any claims about population ethics you
have to have a pop view of population
ethics that you kind of attach on so in
particular total utilitarianism says
um
maximize total well-being so if you can
add someone with
a thousand well-being to the population
that's making the world a f you know
plus one thousand while being better but
there's other sorts of
forms of utilitarianism average total
italianism says increase average
well-being that's the same if you've got
the you know a fixed population of
people but it changes if you're adding
additional people but now if you're
looking at um
uh
but let's just let's even just assume
total utilitarianism for now
um
and we've got a choice between adding
one person
for sure
um
or adding 50 50 chance of another person
with a better life
so it seemed to me that okay we've got
the
we've got that choice
let's say person one has this life
that's positive but just barely worth
living it's really devoured there's you
know there's a lot of suffering in it
that happiness just outweighs it
person two has
most wonderful life that's ever been
lived
and lives like ten times as long and it
just has peaks of joy and creative
insight just imagine your best day but
10 times better every single day
then i think like it's perfectly obvious
that you should take 50 chance of
the one person with a very happy life
and then okay make the person's life the
really happy person like less happy the
person with a life barely worth living a
bit better they will become some range
where we just don't know
because these comparisons are really
hard
um and perhaps there's even some range
of incommensurability so not just that
we don't know but actually there's
fundamental differences so perhaps one
person's life has great accomplishments
and
involves pursuit of knowledge the other
person is just this kind of beach bum
and just like surfs all day and has a
great time and both of those lives are
very good but perhaps it's just very
hard to weigh off those
um weigh those two sort of lives
together
the first view wouldn't deviate from
total utilitarianism at all it's just
limits to our understanding what we can
know about the world
the second one would move away from
total utilitarianism as it's standardly
defined
but not in like a really fundamental way
instead it would just be
sometimes you can say that one outcome
is better than another one
sometimes you can say that equally is
good but sometimes you can't sometimes
one outcome is neither better nor worse
nor equally as good as a second outcome
they're unconventional
and
as long as at least sometimes
one outcome is
really is better than another
then utilitarianism is still action
guiding it's still saying at least in
some circumstances it's clear what you
ought to do
even though in other circumstances it
just says there's no fact of the matter
because
these are both good lives but they're
good in different ways
but the conclusion you said was
perfectly obvious i worry if we try to
extend it from one extra life to the
entirety of the human race like if we
say there's going to be a trillion
people that exist in the future and
either
they will be yeah meh they'll they'll
have moderately happy lives or there's a
50 50 chance they'll have amazing lives
and a 50 50 chance they will there will
just be extinction and no one will exist
i think that there it's not so obvious
and maybe even most people would vote
for 100 guaranteed existence even though
i just scaled up the numbers right
great and this actually um so
uh love how you're placing me
and how deep we're getting into these
issues
so
there's this and it actually relates to
this these issues
before about tiny probabilities of large
amounts of value you start to get into
the say that like the same
kind of formal tools
so the question is
um is value unbounded so
if i have two
really good lives happy lives
is that twice as good
or once you've already got one has
something maybe a second one's still
really good it's still you know making
the world better and virtue of there
being another happy person or does it
make it just a little you know a little
bit less good than the first one did are
they diminishing the turns to value
itself
and the intuitive case for this is very
strong i think
imagine a future where you have
you know populated
the solar system or even the galaxy or
just earth but it's just you've created
this utopia there's a large population
hundreds trillion people all living the
best possible lives
and then i say yeah 50 50 chance of
that going to zero or you can have three
such
utopias and people like well
doesn't see i don't know it does the
gamble doesn't seem worth it
i have those intuitive intuitions very
strongly um
and that suggests that value is bounded
so
just as you know in an individual life
it's plausible that
you can get happier and happier and
happier but there's some kind of upper
limit at least on a day-to-day
um
it's not that just your day you know you
couldn't have a day that's like a
trillion times as good as your best days
um
that might be true just for value as a
whole
um and that would mean that you know
take this flourishing utopian
civilization
have it three times over maybe that's
ten percent better or something because
you're very close to this upper band of
value
however there are
really bad problems for that view too
because if you've got
if you think there's an upper bound to
value
then it really matters how when you make
decisions now
it really matters how many
people have lived in the past well how
many people are alive in different
places in the universe and how good or
bad those lives are because you need to
know am i very far away from the upper
bound in which case
i don't really need to think about them
i can just say okay if i'm far away from
the bounds then
two happy lives or the plot is
approximately twice as good as one happy
life
um but if i'm close to the band then it
really makes a big difference
and that just seems absurd to me the
fact that we ought morally to be like
figuring out like
what were the lives of the ancient
egyptians like and were they good or bad
how many animals were alive in the past
and were they good or bad are there
other alien species and are they good at
bat that just seems absurd to me too
and so again we have a paradox i think
we've got this
issue where any view we have has these
kind of devastating
um
objections
and honestly actually one of the things
i think model philosophy has contributed
most over the last five years especially
as we've started to use some more formal
tools
is demonstrating a whole bunch of these
areas where you can prove
um i mean i call it paradox that's only
in the informal use the term but you
prove um
that
impossibility results is the is the
technical term you have four conditions
four principles each one is just yeah
absolutely this
you've got to you've just got to accept
this principle
couldn't not be true and then you prove
that they're inconsistent with each
other
and
this is one of those cases so um
i'm not saying yeah i'm gonna
but then the thing i should say is
that's compatible with utilitarianism
that's just a diff the view on which we
have this like bound and like additional
happy lives get less and less sex have
less and less additional value
that's utilitarianism but with a
different view of population ethics kind
of slapped on
um and
uh that's actually that category of
views is one of the categories i didn't
have time to get into in what we are the
future but um
that's a shame because they're yeah is
it a very in yeah they're an interesting
and important category of views you
might have
well i guess personally i'm in that what
you call the wishy-washy middle ground
of uh not being a nihilist but not being
more realist either being a
constructivist who thinks that we have
these intuitions we try to formalize
them and
as you say it very often is the case
that you think you're formalizing your
intuitions and you use your formal
system to prove a conclusion you think
is morally repugnant so clearly you've
made some mistake there or you're just
incoherent and neither one of those is a
a
a happy place to land but let me just
push one more a bit on utilitarianism
because
it does seem even if even if you
sort of have diminishing returns to
value or an upper bound on the total
amount of value the fundamental idea is
you're adding up value
or well-being or utility or whatever in
all these different lives and that leads
to a feeling that all else being equal
more people
is better if if all else is equal and
you know derek parfit famously uh
reached what he called the repugnant
conclusion and maybe you could tell us
what the repugnant conclusion is and if
i'm not mistaken your attitude is yes
let's accept this repugnant conclusion
it was he was cheating to call it that
uh so i agree that it was cheating to
call it that
and i'll tell you the reason why
which is that um
[Music]
any again within this area where you
have these very strong intuitions and
they're all inconsistent with each other
so and i actually do think that
the repugnant conclusion is
maybe the least
um repugnant of
uh the principles we'd have to reject
but let me explain so again bearing in
mind that utilitarianism is compatible
with many views of population ethics and
every model of you has to engage with
population ethics we all face the
question of
how should we weigh up bringing new
people into existence is that good or
bad at all so the potent conclusion is
uh the following so imagine you have
a population of 10 trillion people some
large number of people and they have
amazing amazing lives let's say it's
plus a thousand let's use that number
just to mean
really really good lies bliss
and now consider you have some
second population where you can imagine
by population just future of the world
let's say
and they have lives that are barely
worth living let's say plus
0.1
you know it's good they think yeah i am
happy to have lived but i'm close to
indifferent
perhaps my life has just been very
boring not much has happened or perhaps
has had like both happiness and
something in it
but there are a very very large number
of them
let's say there's a trillion trillion of
them or a trillion billion trillion we
can make the number very large indeed
now if you have this total utilitarian
view which is saying
even in cases where you're adding people
to the population
what you do is just add up
the well-being across the whole universe
across the whole future
well then you would get this conclusion
this conclusion that
um
the very very large
population
with trillion trillion trillion trillion
people with lives are just barely worth
living that has totaled greater
well-being than the much smaller but
still very large population of people
with total bliss lives
uh and that
seems the puggling says derek prophet
um
and
he really stuck i mean
he deserves to name the conclusions
because uh you know he really
inaugurated this field and he really did
believe it was the pugnant i mean
before he died he told me that he would
give up on
the idea of there being
moral truth at all
and he was a pretty committed moral
realist he would give up in that idea
before accepting the repugnant
conclusion um
however uh you can prove that if you
you can prove that
there are a small number of principles
within population ethics that are
inconsistent with each other
um
and i'll kind of give you the argument
just fairly quickly so
start off with this uh 10 trillion
people
who live extremely good lives plus a
thousand
um call that the a world
and sec now we're going to change that a
world in two ways
we're going to double it in size so it's
now 20 trillion people
with the original 10 trillion people
we're going to add just plus one
well-being so about a thousand and one
now
um
the other
trillion people 10 trillion people are
going to have lives that just a little
bit less good so plus 998.
um
now has that move and we'll call that
world a plus twice as big you've made
the original people a little bit well
off the new people have lives that are
extremely extremely good
but not quite as good as the well-being
of the lives and people in the a world
does that make the world better
so i'll maybe i'll just ask you you can
uh tell me what you think
well actually no i mean it's cheating
because i've read your book and i i have
had time to think about it and actually
this is the step that i would deny i
think that just adding more people of
equal levels of happiness
is not necessarily better and again i i
started off the whole thing by saying i
don't have the once and for all final
answer in my own mind so i'm happy to
change but that's the weakest link to me
uh so i agree it's the weakest link
actually
and that if you're going to reject the
pregnant conclusion it's this step of
the argument that i'm giving you that
you should object but i mean let's
linger on it so let's say you're one of
these 10 trillion people originally
original people
by making this change you're going to
make your life a little bit better and
the life of everyone else you know
you're gonna move from a thousand
well-being to a thousand and one
well-being
um
and the cost of that
is adding more people who will also have
supremely good lives
in fact lies like close to this bliss
world i stated plus 998
what's your argument for saying that
that's wrong
sure uh and i the intuitive pull of the
argument is is perfectly clear to me um
so i don't have an argument that it's
wrong i have the
uh idea that maybe
um
they're the function that goes from the
set of individual people and their
happiness to the total consequentialism
uh-ness of the whole thing is highly
non-linear and not just additive over
the number of people
uh
so
i mean that might well be true
that doesn't okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop pressing you on
this at the moment
i think you're like at the stage to um
get off the boat yeah
um
and i think actually what you can say is
that yes in this case it would be better
but once well-being levels start to get
lower then it's no longer better and in
fact in the all things considered
view that i
kind of present or endorse in what we
are the future it actually rejects that
step
and so um it the viewer present in what
we are the future is
uh
does not endorse the repugnant
conclusion
even though i'm sympathetic um
uh you know i don't think it's crazy to
endorse it
but okay let's say that you think yeah
this is better you've made the existing
people better 10 trillion people have
moved from a thousand to thousand one
you've added another 10 trillion people
at 998 seems pretty good
um
that we'll call that the a plus world
now um and the move there was by a
principle of like for saying that's
better that's called dominance edition
addition because you're just adding good
people dominance because it's like also
making existing people better
now we're going to move from a plus
world to world b
and to do that we're not adding and
adding anyone at all and in fact what
we're going to do is increase total
well-being and we're going to make it
more equal
because we've got this
world of
10 trillion people a thousand and one 10
trillion people at 998
and we're going to move that to a world
of everyone at
um
999.5
uh that has increased average well-being
it's increased total well-being and now
everyone is equal there was a little bit
of inequality in that former world we've
uh we've made that more equal
again seems like that world is better
like what is their argument why you
would uh
reject that
that move or say that that's not making
it better right i mean you have you have
now lowered the average well-being
compared to the original world
so that's the rub
um
because
okay i've moved but now comparing a and
b yeah i have created a larger
population and have a larger population
of lower average well-being
um
now you can iterate that so i had a to a
plus to b we can do b plus that's 20 to
the to 40 trillion people moving from
99.5 to let's say a thousand and 996.
and so on and so on and so on you keep
iterating going from a to b
then b to b plus to c and so on and what
you're doing is increasing the size of
the population and lowering the average
well-being
keep doing that you end up moving from
the a world 10 trillion people of a
thousand well-being to the zed world of
everyone with barely lives that are
barely worth living yeah um
and
yet but a very large number you end up
with that world being better
and so what are the you know what the
principles you have to reject
well you either have to say that at some
point the move them
something like the a world to the a plus
world is bad
or that the move from
the a plus world to the b world is bad
or you have to deny transitivity which
is to say that
if b is better than a plus and a plus is
better than a then b is better than a
that seems pretty compelling
uh
or
you have to accept a repugnant
conclusion yeah
and in light of those um
yeah
i think it's hard um
my best guess
is that the best thing to do is to the
accept of a pregnant conclusion
but
as i've been saying what i think we
ultimately ought to do is take a
compromise between different
model world views
including different views of population
ethics and
what that ends up giving you
if you really are easing it through
is what's called a critical level view
where there's some dis difference
between
the zero level is the point at which i
as an individual and like indifferent
between having ever been born and never
having been born
and there's just this higher level
and it's only above that higher level
that
uh it's good to
bring someone into existence so bringing
someone to existence with a life that's
barely worth living is not a good thing
might even be bad but if they have a
sufficiently good life then it's a good
thing
and that avoids the repugnant conclusion
um and it does that by rejecting this
dominant sedition principle right once
you start to get to lives that are not
very good
okay thank you for indulging me in my uh
poking about utilitarianism because i
talked about a lot of the podcast but
never quite directly in the way i wanted
to and your
answers are extremely illuminating uh
and no non-dogmatic as well which is
great uh so let's let's wrap up by going
back to the real world and being
practical and and saying that okay if we
have this um
idea that future generations matter and
we can influence them and therefore that
should color our actions in the present
what are the practical things we should
do and actually let me let me let me not
be quite as fair yet let me let me start
with the really hard questions like is
there some implication that
uh
we should
it's more important to have kids than
anything else because you know that
would bring some extra positive utility
into the world
i'll say
two things on that
um the first is that
if you think that
yes bringing a sufficiently good life
into the world is good
then
the overwhelming focus or the
overwhelming upshot of that is that
extinction of the human race is much
worse
um than we would otherwise think
if you didn't have that view
because the loss of life would be huge
astronomical trillions of point billions
of future lives
and in fact like the question of whether
you should have hit kids today
would actually just depend on like how
does it impact the long-term future
including the reduction of extinction
risk
um the
second thought though is like okay let's
just take that question at face value
like is it good to have kids
um there's obviously a very influential
view that says
no um because of the climate impacts uh
i think that argument is really quite
weak
um
and perhaps even harmful um
and i think because it only looks at one
side of the ledger
it looks at the harms that a child can
have you know imposes on the world but
not the benefits too
where
uh if you have children and are a good
parent and bring the kids up well
um
your kids will go on to do lots of good
stuff too
um
they will you know contribute to society
they will pay taxes if you bring them up
well there will be moral change makers
but then also people innovate so they
help
create new technology new ideas
that help make the world a better place
and if you have the view that
well it'd be bad for
you know
me to have kids do you think it'd be
good if there was just like no people at
all
well
probably not i hope not but if so then
it's like okay well where's the line
what's the difference or at least in the
past supposing there'd just been way
fewer people in the past
well
let's say they've been yeah
you know half as many people
well we'd be still living as farmers
we would uh you know the amount of
technological progress and intellectual
progress we've made is because we've had
a lot of minds
tackling these problems um so we would
still be living as farmers we wouldn't
have anesthetic we wouldn't have you
know modern prosperity we wouldn't be
able to travel
and
the same i think is going to happen like
the same considerations motivate um
larger population sizes
um in the pleasant as well
because in fact like the fact that
population is going to peak at 2050 and
then decline after that i think poses
real challenges for us as a civilization
um the standard economic models would
say that
the technological progress that we're
used to would actually stagnate and i
think that could be a very bad thing it
could increase extinction risk
could turn the world into a kind of
zero-sum affair
um
and then the final consideration is just
the benefit to the kids themselves um
where uh
yeah if you can bring if you can be a
good parent bring up your children to
have sufficiently good lives that is a
good thing from the perspective of the
kids
who are i mean i'm happy i was born um
and got a chance to live um and a good
thing from the perspective of the world
so i think that decision whether to have
kids or not deeply personal matter um
uh
certainly not something that like the
government should be involved
um you know
try to legislate or dictate but um is
this one way of being a good citizen and
contributing to the world is having
children bringing up well i think um
yeah absolutely
well is it
i mean i i i understood and and got the
logic behind everything you just said
without necessarily agreeing with it but
are you sort of wimping out there at the
end i mean shouldn't we if you buy
everything you say just conclude that it
is a moral imperative to have kids
well i think
we have a moral imperative
to try and do good things to promote the
good
and there are many ways of doing that
and
for some people perhaps the best thing
is to have a family and bring up your
kids well
um there are other ways to contribute as
well
um which will segue on me onto the other
action but the action points
um
uh that i talk about in what we have a
feature
so um
one is
donations so um you can do enormous
amounts of goods by spending your money
well
um
i have set up an organization called
giving what we can that's encouraging
people to give at least 10 of their
income
uh to the charities that you believe do
the most good
that's just a way that i think almost
anyone can contribute um to making the
world better um you can pursue you know
what career you're excited about but
donate 10 you're having a really big
impact
um and there are organizations that you
can
fund that are
um
[Music]
yeah really doing important work um to
reduce the chance of the next pandemic
or safely guide artificial intelligence
um
or
you know reduce the risk of war
um and so the effect out to some
long-term future fund is one place where
one can give
um
and then a second thing is career choice
so you spend 80 000 hours um working in
the course of your life maybe even more
um so i set up an organization called 80
thousand hours that encourages people to
pursue those careers that do good and
give advice on how you can have the
biggest impact you can because
you can really have an enormous amount
of
impact if you choose to use your careers
in ways that will benefit the common
good
and
so i would you know encourage people to
see this as like
like a menu of options like the many
ways to contribute to the world um i
think that like having children should
be one and if you want to have kids i'm
like great go ahead don't feel
bad about that at least if you're gonna
bring them up well
um
if you don't okay great there are other
ways to contribute as well um you know
donate to really effective places um
i also talk about voting as something
that's just like extremely important
especially politically and you know
well-informed voting but most of all if
you can pivot your career onto issues
that are
to help and work on issues that are
going to be pivotal for the future of
human race enormous amount of good that
you can do i don't know if you know but
80 000 hours the organization is a
sponsor of the mindscape podcast so i've
i've been doing ads for them
oh i actually didn't know that um but it
makes me very glad to hear because uh
yeah i'm sure in your audience uh many
uh scientifically minded
and altruistic people who i think could
take up the mantle and
uh
yeah really try and put some of these
ideas into practice i do want to give
you the chance to respond to i think is
maybe the most common worry about
long-termism which is that and you sort
of came close to talking about it there
uh
if i really thought that let's say
there was a one percent chance of a
pandemic and therefore
uh that would wipe out all the and maybe
i do think that i'm not sure what vive
credence is but they would wipe out all
of humanity then wouldn't i be tempted
to give all of my disposable income to
fighting against that and not give any
of it to helping starving children
around the world is there a danger that
being long-term in our thinking gets in
the way of just doing something
immediate and tangible and good right
here and right now
so this is the trade-off we face and
i call this the horror of effective
altruism the absolute horror of the
world we are then at the moment
where
you now sitting
in your office and me now sitting in my
office live in the mother of
philosophical thought experiments
where
this same question applies even if
you're just focused on the present
generation i fund bed nets to protect
children against malaria that means i've
not funded deworming tablets i funded
malaria bed nets in one country it means
i've not funded them in another
some people
are dead
if you're donating even just thousands
of dollars
because of your decision
and so anything we do has this unreal
opportunity cost and so we need to just
grapple with these hard trade-offs
the next thought is
going back actually all the way to the
beginning of the podcast is
to think in terms of humanity as a whole
the point of view of the universe but
humanity as a whole where
should it be all of my disposable income
or should i split it well from the point
of view of the world that really is not
a large decision you are just ever so
slightly changing the allocation of
resources in the world
and how much money at the moment is
being spent on these issues that protect
future generations
my guess is that something like 0.001
of global gdp
and now what percentage should it be
like i don't know
should it be one percent should it be 10
like
i i honestly don't know i also just
honestly don't know at what point
long termism just stops being
interesting as a flaming at all
and instead
the thing that's best for the long term
is just exactly the same as the thing
that's best for the short term which is
building a flourishing society
at the moment there are kind of more
targeted things that are still very good
from the near term even if they're not
necessarily the very best for the near
term like preventing the next pandemic
like avoiding dangerous biotech
um
but what i am saying is that as a world
you know for the world as a whole
like yes i would love there to be
radically more spending to improve the
lives of
uh the very poorest people in the world
but i would also love there to be
an awful lot more attention paid to
issues that impact
um the entire future of our civilization
um
from this incredibly low baseline that
we currently have
you know that's a very very good place
to end i think we can there's no reason
to think that we can't do both of those
at once uh helping us ourselves now in
the future so will mccaskill thanks very
much for being on the windscape podcast
thank you so much for having me on
[Music]
you